parmi les préoccupations prioritaires du
gouvernement la lutte contre l'exclusion
la politique en faveur de la ville et la
rénovation des banlieues c'est l'un des
grognards du chiraquisme eric raoult de
39 ans qui sera chargée de l'intégration
et de la lutte contre l'exclusion
signe des temps la création d'un
secrétariat d'état aux quartiers en
difficulté secrétariat d'état confié à
françoise de veyrinas député udf de
haute garonne une femme de terrain comme
on dit reportage valérie astruc maryse
burgot il est 13 heures l'avion en
provenance de toulouse est arrivé à son
bord françoise de veyrinas une toute
nouvelle secrétaire d'état
pas de dossier sur le bras juste un sac
objectif faire vite
c'est une pomme que ma porte et le co
pilote dans l'avion
dix ans je pense qu'on n'est pas des
jeunes et je vous apporte votre le
déjeuner sotra tant pis car il faut à
tout prix filet à l'assemblée nationale
pour prendre place sur le banc des
ministres
il est 15h30 sortie de l'hémicycle le
nouveau secrétaire d'état tentent de se
frayer un passage quelques minutes de
répit pour les interviews et les photos
car françoise de veyrinas a en charge
les quartiers en difficulté
un dossier prioritaire rattaché au
ministère de la santé justement onisep
vincent tous les moyens sont bons pour
déménager les dossiers en quelques jours
on a entièrement vidés certains bureaux
les cabinets de madame veil et de
monsieur douste-blazy c'est une
trentaine de personnes qui aujourd'hui
sans vous madame veil pour les
professions de santé et donc je retourne
vraiment mettez quelques chirurgiens le
conseiller technique chargé du budget
déjà parti pendant ce temps les
secrétaires attendent avec un brin
d'amertume
leur prochain patron
on a cumulé un tas de travail finalement
on voit tout ça ne disent pas quant à
lui si il prend tout cela avec
philosophie des ministres il en a déjà
vu beaucoup des ministres en voilà
quatre de plus colette codaccioni
elisabeth hubert
eric raoult et bien sûr françoise de
veyrinas à tous simone veil a souhaité
bonne chance et plus de moyens pour les
affaires sociales et la santé
quelques effusions pour cette passation
de pouvoir cordial une nouvelle page est
tournée
au fond de la salle le personnel du
ministère ne vend rien vu de la
passation de pouvoir l'huissier est lui
aussi venu faire un tour
il a déjà croisé son nouveau ministre
premier contact
excellent
on se trouve à serrer la main et
correctement des ministres qui arrivent
d'autres qui s'en vont c'était une
journée pas tout à fait ordinaire au
ministère de la santé